the culture's become nuts particularly
on race i think that's why
people are now even less likely to admit
that
they're willing to to vote for the
republican candidate there's
so much racial demagoguery we had the
nick cannon
talk yesterday where nick cannon said
white people are savages and
and barbaric and soulless and animals
well puff daddy pee diggity doo dad
is coming out and defending him p
p diddles tweeted out quote nick cannon
has come home
to nick cannon come home to revolt tv
truly black owned we got your back and
love you and what you have done for the
culture we are for our people first for
us
by us let's go can you so the stuff that
nick cannon said yesterday
is pretty disgusting stuff about how
terrible white people are how they don't
have souls
about how you get power from melanin in
your skin because white people don't
have that
they're animals and now you've got an
even more mainstream guy
p diddy coming out and defending that
imagine
if this were reversed imagine if a
popular
white musician tweeted at
i don't know richard spencer or david
duke or somebody and said
david duke come home to revolt tv truly
white owned yes with a thumbs up and you
know white thumbs up emoji
we got your back we love what what you
do and what you've done for the culture
we are for white people first for us by
us
let's go probably that wouldn't go over
very well would it in the culture
and yet we are told this lie that we are
living in a white supremacist nation
of course that is not the case we've
gone over this on this show many other
times
the the there's there's one aspect of
our law that is still
racially discriminatory as a matter of
law that is called affirmative action
and that disadvantages doesn't advantage
it disadvantages
white people and asian people
particularly on university admissions
which is why
a group of asian students sued harvard
university
that's it that's the only one if you're
told that there is white supremacy by
law
you are being lied to and even in the
culture
no sort of nonsense like this if it were
if it were posted by white people would
would ever be tolerated you would lose
your life
you would lose your livelihood without
question
i do we're for our people for something
like that crazy
and yet we are living under this
delusion actually that you know these
these
polls and and these polls about how
people think one thing and they think
other people think another thing and
they think other people think that other
people think another thing
we're all trying to guess where
everybody is because
we are living in a properly ideological
vision and the ideology is
is disconnected from the reality in many
cases
so you're going to see more of this this
is increasingly what politics
is going to become about i hope you
enjoyed that short segment from the
michael knowles show be sure to check
out the full episode linked in the
description or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts
[Music]
you